so what makes you want to come back and
try it all again
um having something to prove um
when you have something to prove it kind
of makes the decision easy
because it wasn't like i was viewed as
the greatest player of all time
so i could step away from that you know
when you're one of the greats you'd be
like yeah i don't really need to go back
you have something to prove it's like
it's like getting the second round it's
like getting that far
and falling short it's like how could
you not as like a as a person that likes
winning
how do you not want to go back to prove
something so well what do you want to
prove
exactly about yourself um exactly
is that i wasn't just derek's puppet
like
you know we were in in my opinion one of
the greatest duos that have played the
game behind
probably two of the greatest players
that have ever played the game
um and there was an aspect of my game
that
made us go to the end and derek be going
as far and allowed derek to be what he
was
and it was just completely overshadowed
it was overlooked and
um i'm cool with it because i love
derrick and i know that he was
incredible like i'm not trying to say
in any way shape or form that i wasn't
there i wasn't a manipulator i wasn't
you know throwing stuff and
strategically running through it but
that was derek and the reason why derek
was able to do what he did
was because of the social aspect of me
just being in with everybody
and it was just looked at as like a
puppet so i got some approved i wasn't
just a puppet
and i'm here to prove it you're not a
puppet are you the puppet master
i i can't describe i would love to be
the puppet master but then i feel like i
would just be
being fake i have watched the puppet
masters and i've watched them all and
i've
literally been with derek firsthand and
i see how he works
because he was himself and like was
explaining his game to me
while we were playing i was just too
young to kind of like pick up on it
and then as you get older and you mature
a little bit and you understand like
where he was coming from and
why he was doing what he was doing and
then register that
it's a whole different it's a whole
different thing for me and he was doing
what i don't think i could have done
i'm not a puppet master i'm not a
manipulator it sounds like uh you
think you're the older the wiser now and
you plan to go in there with a different
mental strategy and and game play way
way different well i went in the first
time i was 23
connie's just out of college just ended
my athletics so like winning
competitions was huge i was like oh i
want to win
that's not a huge aspect to big brother
like it's a part of big brother
um i was just like i want to find a duo
i did that
and then i was just myself like i wasn't
trying to manipulate anybody i wasn't
like backstabbing
but like you know i was lying and you
know
kind of having relationships that i
wasn't that people might have thought
oh yeah cody we're strong but like my
loyalty was only really to derek and how
we could go further
so i i had a part of the game that was
good and i
i think i just need to have a slight
adjustment of what i did the first time
i think i could do well so you guys go
into this
and of course you know it's all stars
these are going to be familiar faces
how much do you study beforehand uh who
could potentially be in there do you
watch a ton of old footage what do you
do
i'm watching i'm watching it all since i
came out here
and before i came out here like i
watched i wanted to watch like
how did the all-stars deal with it how
do returners deal with it like what do
these people do when
they know who they are they know what
their game is
and now they come in a second time um
and it's tough it's but it's an
adjustment like you can't
i can't flip-flop like i can't go in
there and try to be something that i'm
not
because also like these people are smart
everybody that goes into this house is
intelligent like
they'll be like fake that's not who he
is that makes me a little suspicious we
should send them home
so i think it's just an adjustment i
think i'm gonna go in there and still be
me
which i think was the biggest part of my
game is i was just me
and it put me into these relationships
that allowed me to gather a bunch of
information
anything you wish you'd done differently
the first time around um
definitely not i don't know if you're
fishing for cut derrick that wouldn't
have happened
i'll take derek 100 times out of 100 and
then another 100 times after that
but i think just the understanding of
the game like i didn't
you know like i watched it through
college i
didn't really understand like what
causes this game to like churn and how
important
other parts of the game was i was just i
wanted to be competitive
i wanted to be a beast in comps and it's
like
you you watch and you learn from some of
the people that
are great and it's like you don't have
to you don't have to do that there's a
social aspect to this game that is
equally as important might be
at a bit of an advantage though because
even though people
saw you before you've matured and
changed so much since then so do you
think people
are are not gonna know what's coming
from you i hope not i hope
that i want to go in and be
derek's puppet like i want that to be
the conversations that people are having
like
it doesn't offend me in any way like
you're not bothering me like if you
think i'm derek's puppet and you think
that
having me there as a number is going to
help you guys because i'm loyal
that's what i need people to say about
me i don't need people to be like
to watch what i did and and to know i
think i i i think i've won around like
six or seven competitions throughout the
season which is like
a ton of comps to win in a season i won
on the from the final five on there
wasn't a point that i could have went
home because i won every competition
going out
whether it was the veto or the hoh so
like i don't want people thinking of
being like winning a lot of competitions
i want to be derek's puppet
that's a loyal guy he's a loyal dog and
he bring him on our side and he'll do
what we want
that's why i want people to look at me
and i want all the other big competitors
and the winners that are coming back
i want them to be the targets first
without i just want to get my head
looked over
for the first few weeks and then like
let my social and the relationships that
i build
carried me through like that's the
biggest and just being aware of that
like the first time i was not
i'm going to win competitions well who
do you hope you see in there
and who are you nervous to see in there
i would
hope to see my best friend derek
and then nervous to see you really
didn't reach out to him and ask him am i
going to see you
i don't know um
and then getting a little tight around
the collar okay
i'm sweating is it hot i'm like on fire
in here
um the the nervous to see
i it's so hard to answer that because
for me if it was just me i would be
nervous to see nobody
um because i don't think anybody would
look at me as really like a threat
um because my brother played the game my
brother played the game so
aggressively and caused such rifts
um it makes me nervous to see people
that were maybe on the season with him
that he
had issues with like he had he wasn't
really getting along with paul he wasn't
really getting along with devon he
wasn't getting along with
james natalie on his season it's like so
many people from the season he wasn't
getting along with so it's like
if i go in there and i see some people
from this season are they going to
look at me and be like i don't know i
don't really know cody that well but
like i know his brother
and so that he's he's like on my radar
like i don't want to be on anybody's
radar
and i don't think i should be with when
it's in all-stars there's going to be
some big names that pop out immediately
winners like i wasn't a winner
so i don't i don't want to show up
because of stuff that happened on my
brother season and put a target on my
back so that's the only thing that makes
me nervous
about other house guests well what do
you want to tell the audience about why
you are
going to win i think i'm going to win
because i think
i'm a completely different person than i
was
when i went in the first time i've aged
a little bit i've matured i've learned
way more i've dealt with way more
different experiences in my life whether
it's
business personal i've just become a
different
person than i was the first go around
and i think it's for the better
i think i've learned a lot after playing
the game the first time
and coming back i think it's
give me a couple weeks that i don't go
home and i think i'm going to the end
and winning the game
easy okay um
who will be on your mind while you're in
there my girlfriend
that's another big change that i've had
i was single the first time
and i've been dating a girl for four
years wow been together for a long time
that hard to leave her knowing she's
outside with a pandemic going on
yeah that was a part it's her and my and
my family
um because i like some of my family is a
little bit older that's hard but
my girlfriend she's tough she stuff is
nails she uh
and nobody really knows this she was
diagnosed with cancer
when she was 23. um she beat [ __ ] out of
it
sorry for cursing um and um
you know we went through a lot and so
just less because of the pandemic and
more because of our relationship
to be honest if i'm being like brutally
honest like the pandemic doesn't worry
me with her
it's like the tightness like she's like
my rock and vice versa and like talking
to her like
if something happens i call her first
okay in the car i call her
like it's night i call her like not
having that person that vent to
bounce stuff off of it's definitely
tough
i'm gonna miss her a lot she's gonna be
a tough one to kind of
get through because i didn't have to
deal with that the last time
sounds like you wouldn't even i mean
would you fake a showmance just to
play the game no you're not even going
nah that would shatter her in a million
pieces and i would never
i told that's the one thing i thought i
was like i will not do anything to
disrespect you
and the slightest bit um and that's
i mean showmance would be like purposely
doing that even if it's a fake show
mance
um but that's another part i'm gonna
have to adjust what i was doing like i
was laying all over girls the first goal
yeah i can't do that i can't be you know
getting head scratches and tickling arms
and getting back rubs and massages i
can't
so but i think at this point
how do you make that up communication
it's it's a beautiful thing
communication and relationships are
incredible it doesn't have to be
physical so wow you have matured
all right well my last question for you
i mean just overall or even specifically
how do you think the game could be
different because of the pandemic
whether it's
physical touch or whether it's mental
and emotional how could the game be
different because of what's been going
on in the world it's going to have a
heavy heavy effect on the game it's
because
i i don't know like somebody's family
member could have passed because of it
and now they're coming in the house
i don't know how that's going to affect
them like not knowing
what could happen like thankfully i
haven't had anybody
close to me that passed dirt because of
the pandemic or because of coronavirus
and there are there's a possibility that
there's people that come in with that
that's an added emotional
emotional like impact
on top of this game being really frugal
so
i think it's gonna honestly i think it's
gonna draw us
in the house closer because like we're
leaning on each other like
we're the people that are gonna be there
for each other like it's crazy how
the relationships form in this house and
i think with all the craziness going on
outside we all have something that we
can relate to
and that's being in the house together
and playing this game together
i think it's going to strengthen the
bond with a lot of us and i think it's
going to be good it's a distraction
because it's been chaos outside of that
house so i think going in is going to be
a huge distraction for a lot of people